president zinsky it's an honor to
welcome you back to the White House when
President Putin launched his brutal
total invasion of Ukraine in February of
2022 and Russian tanks rolled over
border toward keev there were those who
thought Ukraine wouldn't survive for a
month so no one no one should forget
that for you to be here today again
today nearly two years later
and for Ukraine to be stand strong and
free is an enormous Victory already
Putin has failed fail's effort to
subjugate Ukraine the brave people of
Ukraine have defied Putin's will at
every turn backed by the strong and
unwavering support of the United States
and our allies and partners of more than
50 Nations 50 nations in Europe in the
Indo Pacific and Ukraine will emerge
from this war Proud free and firmly
rooted in the west unless we walk
away the American people can be and
should be incredibly proud the part
they've played in supporting Ukraine's
success we'll continue to supply Ukraine
with critical weapons and equipment as
long as we can including $200 million I
just approved today in a critical needed
equipment additional air defense
interceptors artillery and
ammunition but without supplemental
funding we're rapidly coming to an end
of our ability to help Ukraine respond
to the Urgent operational demands that
it has Putin is banking on the United
States failing to deliver for Ukraine we
must we must we must prove him wrong
United States and Congress must as I
asked last week in this it's stunning
that we've gotten to this point you know
we need to fully appreciate fully
appreciate how it's wrong how this is is
being viewed around the world and being
used by
Russia Russian loyalist in Moscow
celebrated when when Republicans voted
to block Ukraine's Aid last week the
host of a Kremlin run show literally
said I quote well done
Republicans that's good for us end of
quote let me say that again this host of
a Kremlin run show said Well Done
Republicans that's good for us that's a
Russian
speaking if you're being celebrated by
Russian propagandist it might be time to
rethink what you're doing history
history will judge harshly those who
turn their back on Freedom's cause today
Ukraine's freedom is on the line but if
we don't stop Putin it'll endanger the
freedom of everyone almost everywhere
Putin will keep going and would be
aggressors everywhere will be emboldened
to try to take what they can by force Mr
President I'll not walk away from
Ukraine and neither will the American
people a clear bipartisan majority of
people across the United States and in
Congress support your country they
understand as I do that Ukraine's
success and its ability to deter
aggression in the future are vital to
security for the World At Large and I
have repeatedly made clear from our
first day in office we also need Ukraine
to make changes to fix the broken
immigration system here we also need
Congress to make the changes to fix the
broken immigration system here at home
my team is working with Senate Democrats
and Republicans to try to find a
bipartisan compromise both in terms of
changes in policy and provide the
resources we need to secure the Border
compromise is how democracy works and
I'm ready and offered compromise already
holding Ukraine funding hostage in an
attempt to force through an extreme
Republican partisan agenda on the border
is not how it works we need real
solutions I also ask Congress for
funding for Israel to take on Hamas and
confront multiple other threats backed
by Iran in the wake of the October 7th
assault National Security adviser
Sullivan will travel to the region this
week and meet with the Israeli War
cabinet as I have met with to emphasize
our commitment to Israel as well as the
need to protect civilian life and ensure
more humanitarian assistance flows and
reaches into Gaza for Palestinian
civilians secretary Austin will also
travel to the region this week to step
up the international efforts to protect
the free flow of Commerce through the
Red Sea the entire world is watching
what we do so let's show them who we are
America stands for Freedom today
tomorrow and always America stands
against tyranny and against oppression
and America stands with the people of
Ukraine dear journalists I'm glad to be
here and personally thank you and tell
you how Ukraine Val what we've achieved
together defending life and freedom in
Ukraine we are fighting for our country
and freedom and also in Europe we say
for our freedom and yours and this motto
resonates not only in our country not
only in our hearts not only in Ukraine
but also in Poland and Baltic states
mova and others when freedom is strong
in one country it is strong everywhere
when it burns in one Soul it presents
its merits to to others Ukraine have
twice ukrainians have twice LED
revolutions this Century defending
freedom for nearly two years we' have
been in a fullscale war the biggest the
biggest since World War II Fighting For
Freedom we stand firm no matter what
Putin tries he hasn't won any victories
thanks to Ukraine's success success in
defense other European nations are safe
from the Russian aggression unlike in
the past Ukraine can now tackle the
Russian dictatorship so our children and
other nations one have to shed their
blood and sacrifice lives defending
against Russian aggression we've already
made significant progress we've shown
that our courage and partnership are
stronger than any Russian hostility
and we have freed 50% of the territories
Russia occupied after February 24th and
we won the Black Sea and are Reviving
our economy thanks to Maritime exports
Ukraine's 5% economic growth this year
proves our effective partnership and we
have shown no no Russian missiles can
overdo the powerful American Patriot
system
thank you very much and even during war
we are reforming our country and
strengthening our our institutions today
President Biden and I discussed how to
increase our strengths for next year
firstc air defense and destroying
Russian Logistics on Ukraine's land Mr
President thank you very much for your
supporting supporting us and in these
areas like our our victory in the Black
Sea we aim to win the air battle
crashing Russian air dominance this will
this will intensify our ground
adventages in 2024 with our control of
the Skies who controls the skies
controls the wars
duration and today I would like to thank
of course for yet another significant
defense package with our
Defenders value very much second
yesterday I met with American American
defense company leaders they advised us
on how to make our defense Industries
work faster and more effectively thank
you President Biden for this important
initiative we started with you together
Ukraine and America can trans
democracies Arsenal and this is vital
for other free Nations and the us as it
involves your companies Technologies and
Technology advancement and job creation
and it is important to know that two
thirds of American support for Ukraine
remains and works in the United States
third I informed Mr President that
Ukraine has fulfilled all the
recommendations of the European
Commission
regarding the preparation for a decision
to start negotiations on Ukraine's
access accession to the uh EU and we
constantly communicate with European
leaders about our joint steps sanctions
and political efforts to pressure Russia
American leadership is crucial is
keeping this Unity together a Unity that
serves the entire free world and I thank
America for new sanctions and today we
discussed Putin's further isolation and
making him pay for his aggression it's
very important that by the end of this
year we can send very strong signal of
our Unity to the aggressor and the unity
of Ukraine America Europe the entire
free world everything we talked about
today will help us in the year 2024
today's discussions in the White House
and in Congress across both parties and
both Chambers with a speaker we are very
productive and I thank you for the
bipartisan support as we approach
Christmas on behalf of all our Ukrainian
families supered by War and All Sons and
Daughters on the front Ukraine's
greatest wish is to near this War's
Victorious and no one no one but Putin
wants wants a prolonged War we dream of
a Christmas in a peace time of course
and we are walking to T on our
Battlefield success into peace and we
are heading there together with you and
thanks of course to your support thank
you very much Mr President thank you
America slav
Ukraine thank you look we're going to
alternate asking questions we're going
to ask total of each asked two questions
and I will ask the first question uh I
will ask I will recognize the first
question
asker I'll ask a question y all but um
Danny
Kemp um thank you Mr President um for
President Biden um Ukraine's counter
offensive has uh has stalled in recent
months Congress is blocking Aid uh and
Vladimir Putin appears ready to just
wake things out um so what is the
strategy for the US and Ukraine next
year to try and turn this uh turn this
around and if that fails uh at what
point do you say to Ukraine as a friend
uh that is perhaps time to start looking
at peace talks and for president
zalinski um welcome back to Washington
um can I ask you did you uh hear what
you wanted to hear from Congress and
from President Biden um and or are you
indeed more worried than when you got
here thank you very much well let me uh
answer the question first let's put this
in perspective remember how far Ukraine
has come Russia's failed failed thus far
in trying to erase Ukraine from the map
and uh subsume it into Russia Ukraine
has taken back more than 50% of its
territory seized since February of
22 and has pushed back Russian the
Russian Navy so Ukraine can export grain
and steel to the world through the Black
Sea and thanks to the incredible courage
of the Ukrainian people and the
bipartisan support from our Congress but
it's not just American Support there are
more than 50 countries 50 countries
helping Ukraine with military economic
and humanitarian assistance 50 the
burden sharing the US has put up 75
billion doll and our allies and partners
have put up $100 billion dollar and more
than 90% of our security assistance to
Ukraine is being spent in the United
States to provide weapons for Ukraine
and replenish our stockpiles and build
our industrial base we need to ensure
Putin continues to fail in Ukraine and
Ukraine to succeed and the best way for
that to do that is to pass the
supplement yeah yeah can answer in
Ukrainian
please
first I would like to add to the of Mr
President
Biden
ran
[Music]
house
org
count
on the great result thank
you your turn to ask a question yeah
sorry oh thank you for taking my
question Dimitri Ukrainian television us
correspondent uh many republican voices
doubt the ability of Ukraine to win the
war uh Center once um recently even told
that Ukraine need to seed some territory
to stop
fighting uh to be very honest have you
even consider such a step to seed the
territories to stop fighting and Mr
Biden could you please clarify the
policy and of your Administration the
strategy of your Administration on
Ukraine is it about helping the country
to defend itself or to win the war
because it's obviously such a
difference I will begin
okay
for
we want to see Ukraine win the war and
uh as I've said before winning means
Ukraine is a sovereign independent
nation and uh that can afford to defend
itself today and deter further
aggression that's our objective
uh Trevor reuter
Reuters thank you sir um first a
question for both of you um given the
Republican skepticism of the Ukraine
effort do you worry that a second term
for president Trump would be the uh end
of an independent Ukraine that's for
both of you and then for you uh pressor
President Biden um just an update if you
could on the the situation in Gaza uh on
the reports that Israel has begun
flooding Hamas tunnels um and just the
the offensive in southern GA Gaza
generally how long do you think that
operation should last thank
you first of all with regard to uh
political support for Ukraine there is a
strong bipartisan political support for
Ukraine small number of Republicans who
don't want to support Ukraine but uh
they don't speak for the majority even
the Republicans in my view we're in
negotiations to get funding we need not
to promise uh not not making promises
but hopeful we can get there I think we
can and you're right the world's
watching what we do would you send a
horrible message to an aggressor and
allies if we walked away at this time
and it would hurt our national security
you want me to answer the other question
as well with regard
to want say it
again sorry so the the question was just
um if you could talk a little bit about
the Gaza operation Israel flooding Hamas
tunnels and if you've had conversations
with uh BB Netanyahu about how long that
operation should
last well I have had conversations with
BB Netanyahu and uh and I want to make
sure that uh we don't forget uh what
we're doing here we have to support isra
because they're an independent nation
that's being I mean the brutality the
inhumanity the way in which Hamas
treated the Israelis and I mean raping
and burning and beheading I mean just
just beyond comparison Beyond comparison
and uh to anything else that I've seen
since I've been hearing I've been around
for a long time but I think that uh we
have made it clear to the Israelis and
are aware that the independ the the
safety of innocent Palestinians is still
of great concern and so the actions
they're taking must be consistent with
attempting to do everything possible to
prevent innocent Palestinian civilians
from being being hurt murdered killed
lost Etc and uh look um it doesn't uh
lessen their responsibility going after
Hamas to innocent Palestinians and and
uh and Hamas uh look we we
responsibility protect citizens and
ensure they have access to humanitarian
assistance that's why I work so hard
with our Arab friends as well as
Israelis to get humanitarian assistance
into Israel literally getting up to 140
trucks loaded with gear loaded with food
W load everything that is needed by the
Palestinians including fuel so you know
Israel has stated its intent to fulfill
these responsibilities it's very
difficult with regard to the flooding of
the
tunnels uh I'm not well there is
assertions being made that there's quite
sure there are no hostages in any of
these tunnels uh but I don't know that
for a fact I do know that though every
civilian death is an absolute tragedy
and Israel stated its intent as I said
to uh to match its uh its words with uh
its intent with word with actions that's
why uh that's why I was that's what I
was talking about
today question
three I guess I asked that no I just
asked my turn your turn
yeah
r
[Music]
uh
form thank you so much uh my name is Yar
Ukraine for news agency Ukraine next
summer uh the United States will host uh
uh an anniversary NATO summit summit in
Washington DC which which raises a lot
of Hope especially for Ukraine uh
president zalinski U what does the
ukrainians expect from this Summit and
uh do you hope to hear direct invitation
for Ukraine to join the alliance and uh
President Biden under what conditions is
the United States ready to support the
initiative of inviting Ukraine to be
member member of NATO thank
you thank you for your
question uh I will answer very
quickly on this very complicated
question we are not
allies till now we are not me we allies
but we are not members members of NATO
so that's why I think I will pass this
question
to our big
friend President Biden well
look I'm very proud that how strong and
unified na NATO has become and now it's
even larger I uh Putin wanted the
finalization of NATO when I met with him
in uh in
uh in Geneva right after I was elected
and he's gotten the NATO isation of
Finland instead and NATO will be in
Ukraine's future no question about that
but we as we said in villus Ukraine will
become a member of NATO when all allies
agree and conditions are met right now
we we have to make sure they win the
war and uh you know we launched a joint
Declaration of support alongside
president sininsky and the G7 leaders in
villus outl outlining a long-term
commitment to supporting Ukraine's
defense needs we also hosted a defense
industry conference last week here in DC
to get that critical work done so it's a
step at a
time thank you all very very much
includes thank you everybody